こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん中丼とか焼き肉とか食べますでしょうか
僕もん焼肉牛丼大好きなんですけどもあのご存知の通りですね
あれ牛さんをあげてるんですよまあ知ってる人も居ると思います例えばた5社の感謝の
気持ちはは3月だと思うんですよね
いただきますって言うじゃないですがご飯食べるときではを命をいただき
いますという意味を含めていただきますって言って食べてるんであのね牛丼とかパック
白羽美梅って食ってるんですけども
こと感謝の気持ちを込めて食べるほうがいいと思うんですよねで今日のだがですね今
から後悔二人呼んで一緒に牛とたくさんくんですけどもカメラもまだ若いんで
俺に言われたくねーと思うけどそんな若い衆の人たちにですねいただきますのあり
がたみを教えてやろうかなと思いますで強度がですね牛丼食べていると突然牛にか売っ
てるドッキリでございます
書いただけで潮手配させて頂きました
何を食べてるかをしっかりと見ることってとっても大事だと思うんですよ俺達は一体何
を食って何の命をいただいているのか
それをしっかり目に焼き付けるために牛丼食ってるときにその牛丼がなんか帰ってき
たら
よしに代わってたら俺たちこれを食べ前棚とこいつらの命をいただいているんだな
っていうありがたみを身をもって感じて食べ物にそして道渦に感謝の気持ちを込めよー
かなと思っておりますまあツって
生存主になってたらびっくりすると思うんですよねでは早速やってみましょう
大建ねんっ手袋年生
[拍手]
んじゃ社長の生えてるよねー建部んですねー前年に入ってください18歳
21歳ん
26歳だけでこれあれだぞ未成年と成人男性と
のあなさん好きのところ結構寝てバラバラなんですよ坊さん民党も再任で金牛の送って
くれてくれ入るのかっていうか
んだよそういう部分的なものをしっかりと確かめて帰りたいと思います上半身しただけ
だけど食べるがこちらですねはいどうぞ
8名が牛丼に子なのでまた9月信号券買って持っ
メガ牛丼ニコ生でキング牛丼の大きさでございます私はもうちょっとてくれるでしょう
か早速食べましょう
いきますっ入っ良いじゃあ
いただきまーすいただきます
音ん
[音楽]
うん
キャン系と例えば良いはてれば借りたいですね
google 行けとか言っておいてきまーんじゃ者
というわけで見事に牛道を残して彼ら
別の場所でいましたあとはこの牛丼3つを牛に変えるだけでございます付でちょっと
すぐ戻ってきそうな早速牛さんのところに行ってこようと思いますさすが20度んとー
う資産を一緒に発音させるのはかわいそうですね
[音楽]
ました
ています
いらっしゃいます
姉がなしたかわいい
細いんですね遅いですねで今ミルク待ちの状態なんで
中もちょっと凹んであならこれがミルク飲むともうちょっとふっくらしていきますけど
なるほど明かりにちゃんですか in the バイ
実はああああ
何度食べられる牛さんとてが魅力だソチナってたから違いがあるんですか違いマーサー
の種類が根本的に違って阿蘇はねそうですをに来ようっていうのは黒毛和種って言って
体が黒い
アーニー下し乳牛っていう牛乳を飲みもは皆さん良くして白黒のブースター員ってやつ
であったり
これはジャージー種って言う
ちょっと白プロ主さんよりも脂肪分も強い
オーディオだすっていう子さんですそうですね
みるゴジラの仕事なんでそうなんですよ
可愛いメガネっ
こんな可愛い述べるとちょっと
g 3でなくなっちゃうのでこれは女の子なので流入を出す
結構一般の方知らないんですけど牧場にいる資産は全部女のうってどうなるんですか
オスがもう肉なっていますあそうなんそうでないけど
当然われわれ着てる女そうな線産業動物って言われてると思うなのでどうしても人も
だめだ
[音楽]
ブーブー駅
食べたり犬4 no
g 生きている間にどんどん声圧優しさをいっぱいかけてい
の大雪しています結構4月の人はみんなこの女にある
[音楽]
食べられると思う
嘘だと食べられちゃうんですよねそうですねボスは結構お肉になる
おとん
やらないけどなんかなぁ
[音楽]
可愛いロリソロですねえっ
彼ならん
県を挙げて使います
野草まだですよ
[音楽]
ua
勢いが凄いねこれ全部飲んじゃいますよ
全部ねあ1 l あってねまじですかあんたユーチューバーに向いてるねー
2力が強いですよねずっいつも力強いに着床シーンだろうな
喜びのまでがはいというわけでターゲットは想像が帰ってくるんでいうゾーンが牛さん
になっていたらどういう話せば裏消化
松葉小待ってるん
ちゃうねっ
[音楽]
あいやのん
どうしたってどうしたかえっなにこれ
me
受けないいやいやっ大会兼財布えええええ
持っん
[音楽]
ええええええ
うううう
ni
car
バッハ
俺たちがな66.3たくさんねなんかねごめんねじゃないんだけどもさんないことだ
からねさんどんなにか
の気持ちを込めてあーこれからもねいただきましょうする時の音より装弾数を込めて
食べましょうねはいしっかりでも入っちゃう幕田
犬ああああ voodoo